social commentator and Bitcoin expert
Leia Halpin he joins me to break down
the potential digital cash nightmare
looming and how it could be used to
force Eco extremism on all of us hi Leia
hi good to see you thanks for having me
okay so are we talking here about the
complete elimination of cash if we had
some spare notes under the mattress
would they be worth anything
they could be worth something
um but equally they could also be worth
nothing we don't really know yet whether
cash would be
um not not accepted in certain stores
but what we do know is that Central Bank
digital currencies are certainly coming
and we saw the um the president of the
European Central Bank Christina guard
she was talking about
um them coming this week even in the U.S
um Jerome Powell the chairman of the
Federal Reserve was also talking about
the lack of anonymity that um a central
bank digital currency would have and we
also know earlier this year at Davos
they were talking about the tyrannical
nature of a central bank digital
currency and that a new Bill of Rights
something sort of to that effect would
have to be drawn up to ensure that um
people's rights and Liberties aren't
impinged on
um that doesn't give me any confidence
um in the future of it because we know
that whatever kind of bit of Rights is
drawn up they'll just you know throw in
the bit in a bit like they did with the
Nuremberg code and the vaccines um you
know when you're not allowed to coerce
people into taking foreign substances
that's right remember when the
philosophy of doctors were was first Do
no harm that went out the window with
the vaccine didn't it Leia and let's
talk about who wants this who's pushing
for a cashless Society is it our
government is it other governments or is
it an unelected elite
well I believe it is the unelected elite
which is in control of all governments
so the world economic Forum are talking
about actually bringing out a carbon
allowance so each individual in this
world will be given a carbon allowance
which means there's a certain amount of
carbon that they are allowed to emit
this is easily put into effect through a
central bank digital currency because
the currency is programmable it's
digital which literally means it can be
programmed to be spent on certain things
and people might say you know this
sounds pretty crazy but I think it's
totally realistic if you just look at
the um the height of the covert pandemic
in Canada for example you had if you
weren't vaccinated you had to be
chaperoned to go into certain stores to
ensure that you only bought essential
items because you know you're
unvaccinated and therefore you know
you're you're dirty and dangerous so
with essential Bank digital currency
what that basically means is it's a lot
more um efficient now to um to
discriminate against people because you
don't need to have those covered
Marshals you just program the money so
that unvaccinated people cards spend
that money on certain items
um there's also really uh another
dangerous thing which I just want to
explain as well the money can also
actually expire so what this means is
during times of economic uncertainty
central banks actually like to and print
more money in order to stimulate the
economy because they need that money to
change hands so we could get to a
situation whereby they say um okay guys
you know for your greater good of course
we need to stimulate the economy if you
don't spend let's say 10 of your current
savings what you have sitting in the
bank in the next three months that money
is going to expire
um and that's pretty awful it means you
know you can't build long-lasting
generational wealth it means you're
forever a slave to the nine to five
it sounds like the end of Human Rights
the end of personal autonomy and the
idea of a carbon allowance that
essentially rations the number of
flights we can take every year uh
possibly how much we drive our car or if
we own a car it might even be that we
can only have steak once a week this is
the extreme Outlook if we if we are
slaves to these digital currencies
absolutely it's really concerning and
again I always like to look back to what
happened over the last two years they
literally limited how much time we were
allowed to spend with our loved ones we
weren't allowed to go into hospital to
see um you know elderly um family that
were dying and that were sick so to
think that they wouldn't um limit what
we're allowed to spend on certain items
would simply be naive um you know you
could go to fill up your car but your
Central Bank digital currency gets
blocked or refused because you know you
bought too many plane tickets and I
don't think people understand the
severity of this money is literally the
energy which fuels your life if you do
not have freedom of money you don't have
freedom of anything you know you can't
buy that ticket to go to uh protest the
lockdowns you know you can't um you know
feed yourself with the kind of food that
you'd like to feed yourself you know
maybe you know your money only works to
eat bugs because you um to buy Bugs
sorry because you bought too much meat
this week so when you control the money
you control the world
that's right this is not Science Fiction
it's not a conspiracy theory is it Leia
The Smiling fascist Justin Trudeau in
Canada throws the bank accounts of
truckers who were simply protesting
against vaccine passports and China has
the social credit system uh this is real
this is not a drill explain how it works
in China and why we must resist
so essentially
um because China is that communist state
and that communist Nation everything
that you do is monitored and tracked so
if you say the wrong thing you like the
wrong thing on social media on their
version of social media then you're
given a credit score and if your credit
score Falls too low because you know you
held that wrong opinion
um then your money will be refused so
you and I simply having this
conversation could potentially bring our
social credit score a little bit lower
so you know if I'd like to buy a plane
ticket back to England so I can come on
your show um or I can see my family my
social my cbdc sorry could get um
refused because I had this conversation
with you bringing my social credit score
lower it's a little bit like actually a
Black Mirror if you've seen it Black
Mirror is literally just this Netflix
program which shows us a very realistic
tomorrow